[Music]
four months ago janine anyas was
president of bolivia
now she's under arrest accused of
staging a coup against her predecessor
evo morales
shortly after being detained in the city
of trinidad she was flown to the capital
la paz
to face charges of terrorism sedition
and conspiracy
anyas is a conservative senator and at
odds with the socialist party that now
governs under president luis arsegh
he's a former prodigy of morales the
former president she's accused of
pushing out in 2019
to seize power she says the charges
are fueled by political revenge
it's an irregular detention because i
was never summoned in addition
as a former president i'm in a unique
situation but even amid all the abuse
and the outrage i'm here
a group of opponents and supporters
gathered outside the prosecutor's office
there was no coup the former president
was involved in fraud
and she took over the presidency through
constitutional succession
although divisive her detention isn't a
surprise
while in power anyas was accused of
siding with security forces to shut down
dissent
she came to power undemocratically and
within her first week
she oversaw two different massacres and
offered immunity to the soldiers that
carried out the massacres
and for the next year carried out a slew
of human rights abuses
the political crisis goes back to 2019
when protesters took to the streets
accusing morales of stealing his
re-election
under pressure the once esteemed
president resigned and fled bolivia
anyas then proclaimed herself interim
president
more protests followed and dozens of
people died
after she took office now other
politicians in her party
also face charges
we are talking about two former
ministers the former minister of justice
and the former minister of energy people
who have conspired or committed crimes
of sedition
in our country will be investigated
while some say the arrest of anyas could
lead to her political downfall
it's already reigniting tensions in the
south american nation
katie lopez elijah al-jazeera